this is East Africa the Great Rift
Valley a land in constant upheaval the
flamingos and baboons here at Lake
Bogoria live in harmony they share this
landscape and all it has lost
they may not be compatible but in the
midst of a glorious bounty they can
afford to be indifferent in July after a
successful breeding season nearly four
million flamingos gather along the seams
of the Great Rift Valley they clog the
inlets and crowd the local residents
the baboon's who live here all year
round can't help to take notice of the
sheer numbers of new arrivals some
babblers have never seen this many
flamingos before
and some of them don't know how to
behave
there are so many birds at Bogoria that
they trip over each other in order to
escape baboons are meat-eaters but this
is something unusual for baboons
choosing between fruits and flesh is a
simple matter for these newbies
until now such an orchestrated attack on
flamingos has rarely been witnessed or
recorded
the graceful wading birds become a
buffet of pink feathers and crimson for
the young have discovered a new taste
and they like it perhaps this is
nature's coldly in different way of
restoring balance